tell you what man what's up bro I'm
looking Taylor a bit of mess deep taking
what you're looking you're in that Sonia
my mouth's all swollen what were you
doing
you got a great mouth can I be honest
with you and can I ask you a question
and that's okay I have some dear self
well no but I want to ask you a question
we know that that's not natural so my
little does your lip who do who do
somebody does your eyebrows your lips we
know that you don't know we think right
right Courtley I woke up like we have
somebody from E probably shooting your
lips can you imagine I did what would
you do if I gave it with E and you're
like what's wrong with your face like II
thought I need them well might want sell
out my wife was she's like he has his
brows done I go no he doesn't sweetie
knows I go let me explain something to
you how long's I know yeah I know
brows I go alright and I brought a
picture of you as a kid yes same exact
same college that I go unless he was
doing his eyebrows when he was a French
robot which is the craziest weirdest
costume the wind kid I want to be a
French robot throat giving out
croissants my mom's like these are
expensive let's think about croissants
tea was fun man well it's the help well
by the way can I just say one thing
before you I want to hear about San
Diego coming store I'm gonna tell you
this dove Davidoff and I have had
weekends down there where where we
looked at each other and we went I went
that was a good time and he goes no no
it was the best time the best was the
best actors you share that condo I will
I would and you have been in a while
that condo now yeah I mean that's a
multi-million dollar place yeah all the
beach all redone right on the beach the
fact that we don't headline down there
together you need to do a show with a
tragedy to be fun huh well dude we'll do
blow till our hearts stop we're not in
the well anyway well ruin will ruin our
relationships we'll just take a bunch of
Viagra like tic tacs and see what
happens I'm down man I mean dude it was
the things that would go on how hard I
agree we got to do that how hard we
laughing at my scooter video I sent to
you before I posted it look uh you broke
that scooter I broke the scooter I had
to pay for the scooter cost you a lot of
money not cheap well you know where the
the handle connects to the body I think
it literally snapped enough yeah it's
not how the kid I would get around a
screw all the time not motorized one
like a regular one I told Jen I feel
this rumor that trig a students kitty
goes yeah I feel like you're too big oh
shut up and film it accuse literally
snapped in half my god
yeah you're not then we just walked away
it's no scooters not made for men in
their mid twos
I don't think so now I was cruising
though I got a new one right out that
cruise around all weekend really yeah
look like real bunch of those look like
three is so is Jay Buster came down and
me three of us on scooters going from
cops coffee shop we look like some sort
of scooter gang that will hold you down
suck your dick wait one time Chris
D'Elia was opening for Dov and I and
well they were down we're down in San
Diego and as Chris had been doing
Stanford maybe two years maybe less and
Chris is what blood build on reels about
Chris D'Elia is he's a [ __ ] weirdo
okay as in he's got he's definitely on
the spectrum okay same [ __ ] over no he
brought 13 t-shirts and he kept changing
his shirts and I was like and I would I
was started [ __ ] with him and I go
you're gonna wear that like throughout
the day huge change over for you we have
to get ready no we're just walking down
the boardwalk so he's like he goes he
goes he puts one shirt on and he goes um
I go ooh
and he goes what I go nothing he goes
huh and it runs back in changes his
shirt comes back out I go you're gonna
wear that and dunkels don't do this
because he was crazy and I did that to
him he changed his shirt about 13 times
really changed every shirt
finally puts out a bad tank top and yeah
his chest is all hairy and it's a slope
and it looks like [ __ ] and how long ago
was this dude this must have been 10
years ago probably 10 years ago it was
[ __ ] crazy
it was 10 years ago and and we so he's
walking now in down the boardwalk in San
Diego is full of actually aggressive
dudes right I told my you know me I
never go out till my breaths if you go
out you watch your P's and Q's it's a
lot of Marines a lot of Ecology seals so
maybe seals but many Marines like to
you'll be careful yes yes a lot of young
dumb alcohol a lot of testosterone yes
you know a lot of hot girls everyone's
vying for the attention yeah a lot of
muscle a lot of a lot of working I've
always had problems when I went down
there
well proms never and so and and and
biker gangs too there's some that they
like to hang is this stuff so Chris is
just lollygagging just lollygagging all
loose armed and loose necked and just
his hairy chest with that and yeah it's
like a it's like a it's like four colors
the tank top it's just what he would
call dope and it's ridiculous like I was
like you belong if you are a girl in an
American Apparel ad I would say that's a
sexy tank top you are wearing this with
your impossibly hairy chest and you just
don't give a [ __ ]
with your skin your vampy they so
[ __ ] vampires like dude you sleep in
a coffin during the day obviously so so
a little tense so would he go on and do
like 10 minutes than you and of would
like split he would you like yeah he
would do like 20 minutes and then Dov
and I would do 45 it was a great show
yeah hell yeah and so he and he walks
walks through and there's this dude this
big kind of rough bully and I can see
him kind of pushing his way through the
crowd and it catches a side of Chris and
he just can't believe like a camp it's
frustrating it's frustrating and I he
was so funny because he looks because
he's trying to catch eyes with Chris
Chris completely could give a [ __ ] and
he goes like this he looks at Chris
[ __ ] he goes hey Chris doesn't me
thing is whatever man Chris does not
ring he's just so appalled by his
[ __ ] tank top hey look at Chris I go
that guy wanted to fight you and Chris
goes it doesn't matter does it because
he could punch me in the face and I
would never fight him I go what would
make you fight like if you were with a
girl and he goes now now I go so what
would he goes maybe if somebody like
push my mom I would like say don't he's
not that he's not that tight he's a
great kid we actually got slammed we
were walking and and these really big
strong looking young dudes stop their
truck this big we don't have muscle
trucks yeah kind of trucks there's a lot
of trucks up should have bull balls they
always have balls hanging out there
there's a lot of lifted trucks that's
right this is a lifted truck with just
you can see it's balls yeah that bull
balls hanging for this deluge Yeah right
with a tailpipe man central and just
these [ __ ] rough dudes stop and I go
oh something's gonna happen here and
these guys have necks like fire hydrants
Chris Chris they get out chris is like
oh [ __ ]
and I'm looking at the you know me I
take in bodies I'm like Jesus Christ
they're [ __ ] big strong guys talking
about
well you've been Afghanistan man oh
that's cool yeah are you like that I'm
talking about go
I got to get back in I go what were
those guys they're Navy SEALs they
they're all they were my classmates they
got into the Navy SEALs I was like
that's really cool he goes whatever I
can't imagine it but they're like the
elite of the elite he goes oh god dude I
don't give it you do care I think
everyone with a beard down in San he is
a Navy SEAL we didn't stay in line for
coffee shop I saw like a guy in shape
with a beard looking relevant prior
names yeah I probably goes probably not
usually what the odds are like that's
true that's right Joe
I want to be like bro like no [ __ ] well
they're all crossed in and out reach a
healthy tattoo I was saying this that MJ
was saying the same thing it's the one
place I'd leave LA for really if I could
work if I could do my job done that move
this ending well cuz you love the beach
and son I just I just love how slow it
is and it's so everything so nice and
you're surrounded by water and good food
and the ratio has to be four to one yeah
it's the nuttiest thing I've ever seen
just just like crazy these shorts and
they're just they're they're like this
is my body food and just like Beach
bunnies and do Pacific be Jude's pee
dude dude yeah yeah I could live there
huh too old to go out you do it well I
don't go out I'm just saying like La
Jolla and specific is where I would live
I wouldn't live in peace PB I'd live in
La Jolla this this weekend I'm I doubt
it I went out with mr. Luke Rockhold and
his crew and we went to bars in Los
Angeles and their youngest to old for
that Obama I can't believe you welcome
told so what it was look like the sugar
daddy you look the guy I sure that they
let that my rump hole that's right a the
bill that's right I'm the old I'm the
old gay queenís we have established but
but it became very aware of the old gay
al fronting the bill they took me to a
club and I was like in a good home well
it was in it was in Santa Monica near my
house you went to bungalows no no it was
it was a place on 2021
was it outside it was inside and there
and where I was there a mall bodega all
young people into bodega maybe I thought
you kind of dark inside I'm like
Restoration Hardware but club style
probably yeah also it's a I think
they're all happy shopping
yeah like sabia I'm in there and it
school student dude stood and they're
just those days those guys like Ted
shots and everything else I'm like of
course I'm not doing well Luke Luke's 33
but literals Luke is kind of like
probably the winding down hold his front
pressure of training camp his friends
are all the American lost a little all
great guy all the American lost there in
the 30s oh yeah there's a lot of there's
a lot of that but the surfers surfing
lifestyle surfers and everything else
but either way I just for me they were
having a great time for me I'm just too
old yeah you old well I'm the 51 year
old you can't be 51 you can't be hanging
out what's wrong with give a good meal
and talking like in those places you
can't talk yeah yeah I but I guess the
praline for girls yes
to me there's nothing worse when it went
like I just want to talk to my friends
when I have a group of friends or just
focus on fun girls yeah I do just run
it's like it's like being in a group of
hunters yeah I'm like okay can we just
focus on something else
let's hang we have a legit conversation
you laugh I have a conversation but
there are some dudes are just they can
of all they care about it's about hunt
next spot let's go over here I heard
there's tons group yeah that's what and
one of their not Luke one of his buddies
was that way he was the he was the
ringleader let's go you wanted to seek
different places because what there's
not enough girls in here yeah I think
you know your friends like to tear it up
he started laughing it did but there's a
lot of that in this in this country in
general we if you can find it there's
also not a lot of it I don't not around
that at all and the people I associate
with aren't around that at all like
you're not around that daliyah is not
around that most people I know yeah we
don't our crew doesn't really drink and
drug that's that's the difference right
no we don't we just want you to do I
don't think you could do it and pull off
with it well that's what I always say
like well you can't do it and literally
pull off like what daliyah schedule your
schedule my skill not even even in my
end of my albeit party sometimes or just
with a round of people and and people
back you wanna do some blow and I go but
I but it's Wednesday
I have to wake up yeah it's like we're
gonna be up how do you have a lifestyle
where you can see it's rare I even go
out to eat I went out me and Joey went
out to eat the place cup I don't say its
name because I don't [ __ ] on them but
this steak house in Brentwood it's new
steak house where you can figure it out
you know probably the most expensive
steak house I've ever seen even the mad
that the price is like today it's
expensive here man we go there it could
celebrate my show got announced and
bought a new house so I went to go
celebrate there and God man not like
really going out to eat I like to just
be at home oh he's out you're all right
yeah I love being at home but the food
man was not yeah a lot of packaging
around regular four yeah it literally
looked like I walked in Restoration
Hardware but they serve steak goes dark
nice atmosphere and the food I was like
dude I would say almost every restaurant
every high-end restaurant in Beverly
Hills is that way that's what I think
I've eaten it every I'm talking about
great steak houses
I think but beau is so beau is like Oh
Bobo's the Maserati of steak houses yeah
they Sally looks good sounds good actual
product yeah we're gonna hang out and
pick up you're doing the scene yeah yeah
and if you're seeing Lily for Cougars in
the feeling for a dicksuck in a filet
you get yes you can yeah yes you can a
lot of people are into a lot of
professionalism going on there is that
the BOA steakhouse yeah it's well it
looked again it looks great not terrible
food now it's a scene but also corporate
I can get yeah it's a chain I can give
you ten restaurants that but you want
the best state you literally you want
the best steak in North America you go
to scope and get the Tebow yeah it will
knock your dick in the dirt it'll knock
your dick in the dirt that's 100% true
you had a little party huh a little
party how dare you I know you were
missed I had some fun had some fun I
smoked weed now you know I'm not a big
weed smoke who gave you we mr. Will
Sasso came up he was playing a bully he
was like he was yet weed and he's like
you gonna smoke some weed we're gonna
knock off a gas station you're gonna
distract the old coot distract the old
coot and he would push the thing in he
goes glass
ah and I took like three shallow hits
I was hot till 5:00 in the morning you
should I hate that and he was me
I allowed the munchies I got the
munchies I I ate you did you have it um
did you have it catered yes I had that
same guy no different job and that
blasco's that con O'Connor's are based
what did he would you guys serve this
all right ready
hold on because before you would before
you would have it you ate a turd it was
you had hold on now listen to me in a
man do you notice as well when he had
your open house party yeah we moved to
Calabasas yeah that was a prom guys had
disaster view worst food disaster on
disaster now this dude will make make
you a steak a pork some pow pow chicken
you're not even ready and I'm not ready
to even talk about a chicken I'm not
ready to talk about it yet what's his
name
Colin O'Connor a young Irish bothered me
for one year on my email one [ __ ]
year didn't stop bugging me I want this
guy so persistent he's such a badass
showed us a persistent I say stalker
showed up I say stalker who can cook bro
he blew my mind and then cleaned
everything and and why does he get it
stay the night and he had sex with my
wife and then he got there and then took
your dog Craig nated my wife in any got
killed you Courtney and you bet they're
in the way and and now he's living in my
house so here's the thing I haven't in
I'm gonna have an in-house chef um is
good for made me laugh who else he gave
us your high so that was high people
neighbors friends I don't know friends
that I know it came up Sasso just south
of Grillo Grillo his wife don't have a
lot of friends do we live with we don't
I just realized I just got a little sad
I just got a little sad I did you came
out you wet I knew I wanted to get that
out of you cuz you go friends what I
know but who you went neighbors it's
that story about my that's my friends
their wife and from the Family Guy my
friends are my friends are here say hi
yeah yeah I hear you man
I hear you just realize that guys your
house ah I got mad people at my
birthday's March 18th off people over
what we gonna do for your birthday
Oh we'll hang all our friends well
friends and then I'm making like Leah
Rogan Brian tony client cardiogram
header Hannah all my friends in Denver
probably won't come I check him over we
should get him out maybe have a real
rage whoo right I don't know a lot of
our friends are tough though our friends
are tough because everyone's so busy
everyone's either on the road yeah are
they doing this show or it's the only
day awfully stuff to it forget anyway
huh uh but you know you got to make time
I've sad story but I gotta make time
yeah my friend was killed this yesterday
I was fun with his nanny yeah I was fine
t-boned by a bus do I know this guy I
would probably know who he is he's a
he's a big sports agent his name is Dan
Fagan great guy great guy bring him up
to five year old son the car in the
hospital Oh praying that his son pull
through he lost my wife nanny lost her
life and Dan Fagan and a great guy man
just a great person how did spell his
last name oh this says Dan Fagan was a
musician best known for that's not him
right no so that's what Dan Fagan agent
big agent ooh I mean big big clients I'm
an MBA Jeff yeah that's right that's
exactly right
killed in Colorado crash there is o in
Denver uh yeah an aspen is such a bummer
really great guy [ __ ] great guy and
anyway
[ __ ] happens very quickly how about this
and I think I can speak about this I
think I can speak about this dan was uh
so you know Frank grill Frank Martin boy
Frank Martin who's got a brain tumor
right and he's really close to Dan Fagan
but what happened was when he found out
his boy died he was like dude I thought
I was the first guy to go and now my
buddy goes and in a way it was like this
he's like you know we're all
I just got to make them a hold stop
addiction Jesus Christ he had John Wall
DeMarcus Cousins Dwight Howard he had
just seen his house in the Hills his
house nails was the craziest thing I've
ever seen
and a great guy a great [ __ ] guy and
you know you just pray for that little
boy
god I hope his sons okay yeah it feels
sick yep
but the but I thought when I woke up got
the call from Jimmy Burke and I woke up
and I went you know um you got to make
time you got to make time for your
friends make time for everything happens
him good okay that's our that's our
podcast guys so you really know that no
I lean on that note and thanks so much
she's great that there's such a shame
yeah
yeah it's kind of nuts yeah everybody go
after this did you do I have to grind
things to a halt and then I like to have
a pause let's have a pause and a nice
line here blow together on my birthday
why we gotta celebrate
that's why you got a [ __ ] rage against
the night we call it raging against the
night as you get older [ __ ] this let's
party bro but [ __ ] we do blow it's got
fentanyl some of these heart stops ah
[ __ ] we're celebrating I don't know
where you go after this that's done
right
hey how about the purple walls in here
Gentile is great does that was Grady
Bryan uh it does look great with a hint
a pilot there's some violet there's some
violet great choice bro they put like
red or something I went well which one
did you pick you show man it that's
clearly a shade of color block yeah I
might be colorblind then I'm not great
at I'm not great at picking you know
colors art I've spent way too much money
on an art piece of wood he told me how
much that was a fireplace yeah my friend
and Doug Davidoff who knows art he goes
he goes yeah I go yeah yeah I go what do
you think about my thing but you know I
guess when somebody says that y'all are
[ __ ] like this comedian told us who is
it Ted mines Mozingo down from Vancouver
did Martha Stewart's lights up
Ted months ten months I think it's
[ __ ] amazing
sick dude it's so detailed nice turn on
right now oh no no we have to hook it up
this [ __ ] drove down from
Vancouver what take him out to dinner
for real I would have I would have where
is he is he's still in town no they left
all right ed turn around I swear to god
I'll take you to dinner and then I'll
give you a steak ahead I won't but what
I will do is do a FaceTime with you
there you go Brandon will FaceTime but I
will take you I'll take it for real get
in touch with chin and if you are if you
are in town I'll take you to dinner I'm
not gonna be there but I will Skype
FaceTime on your phone I'll do your
wives behind does your and then we'll
just well it's like we're at dinner
that's a big deal for real I'll take you
cool is that I will take him although
you can do it when you're in Vancouver
ah apology you subtle a bit goddammit
sorry guys we are really sorry you did
everything you could and I did
everything we both did it's just that
you're you're too talented now and ii
don't think you think about remember we
originally canceled it because you were
gonna go to Dubai or Iraq or some [ __ ]
stand up which is very idea and then it
didn't fall through so we both I was
like oh I'm not going that Bryan I'm
gonna do it so I cancelled they like
they don't weekly like ax I'm not doing
it we do it again and I like well now
yet Showtime so then yeah it was it was
cursed from the start
cuz remember Christmas time we told our
agent like man I got this well I'm
willing to hear about this joke I'm
waiting hear about this and then they
still booked this it's not on us man
yeah so but we'll both be back up there
man Cooper's one of our favorite spots
and when we do would take that gem out
to dinner who bought sorry Dan months
once they take out designer mindset or
do you post mates to your house and I'll
sign the chicken yep will sign it I'll
have the guy sign on the rotisserie
chicken yeah how cool is that thing
though it's incredibly heavy too I don't
know yeah I don't know if roomy out up
it's so heavy on this wall I doubt well
wouldn't we have any special screws I
can get really well hire somebody to
hold it just like during the show sweaty
we have a contest see who can hold it
the longest before they first evolve
yeah and then we won't take him to
dinner balls will face time with him
that's what about idea everything else
get a brother anything any news on your
show getting picked up yeah yeah we're
getting closer and closer you're just
waiting no I got I got news it's I got
even better news
you can't you know it's it's it's very
it's it's it's it's very close so I can
get in trouble if there's a very very
good chance it's the the it looks more
like the way more like not which is in
this business is big yeah yeah I
actually to the point where I did a
video of my life and the people in my
life my family and I sent it to my my
parents and my my mother and
father-in-law I said I just want you to
know I kind of I like to do these weird
things this before I found out my friend
died I like do these weird things where
I mark how lucky I am I go III have more
than I deserve and I feel very lucky and
here's why and I just sent that off I'd
like to make that I like to Anchorage
and you gave them the the heads-up that
you got this show yeah I just gotten a
call from from and you did it a power
that you didn't include you're the first
person I called when I hit show time
because I'm waiting to really I'm
waiting to tell you when it happens you
know you know I mean you told you feel
like right now I call you and go hey bro
even closer all right yeah you know what
I'm saying and you know me how long have
I been doing this yeah you're skeptical
often does it always have how you know
anything can happen but when they start
putting money down on the table and
they're holding every time uh sounds
good no not yet
yeah yeah I do I like the pilot that was
good yeah yeah I'm tight-lipped but it's
looking good and if you say it's a good
that means it's really good did your
skeptical hip on I'm the opposite so
yeah it might not like yeah it's gonna
do badly that's why I love it that
whenever you get I mean it's it's crazy
whoa JB this Wednesday brother that's
right we gotta blast it out no man
that's so exciting at rehearsal today
record tomorrow it just looks it looks
really good what are you wearing first
can you say like yeah the first episode
is rank II no well so check out so
Saturday Deontay Wilder fights on show
timing it's Ortiz
for the Heavyweight Championship so I
have an interview with Deontay Wilder in
New York and then Frankie Edgar fights
as the co-main event of UFC 222 I mean
Frankie got his favorite pizza joint so
I have that interview on it on Telemundo
cuz I was just wondering where I would
make you're in Spain are you from ER
well that's a picture obviously where
it's a I'm on the new darkest that's the
picture that variety picked
I'm not mad variety picked it up though
now I've never been in variety that's
huge
it's actually huge was I gonna say yeah
but so it's D Ontario out of Frankie oh
you're in the first episode and then
also Paulie Malignaggi I do a drinking
game with him he seems like a guy to me
that's gotta hang next time I'm in New
York this week but I'm gonna be there
next month month after you got to come
and we got to go out Paulie Paulie they
called Magic Man Paul in Magic Man he
ain't on
he owns Brooklyn he owns Brooklyn owns
it and and you know that I'm I'm gonna
have to ask you just a couple questions
off the job just so just so Michael
break it down and it will be our entire
dinner and breaking down your cab really
he's a savant I'm all over that he's the
greatest guy ever yeah yeah he's on the
debuts this Wednesday and then so twice
a month you get it on Facebook YouTube
so people in England and Dublin and
Austria like are we gonna be able to
watch we don't have Showtime yes
it's digital and then once a month is
like the I don't wanna say the best
stuff but below the belt on peds it's a
super show on Showtime network TV hmm so
that's how it's going down heather
locklear arrested for domestic violence
she beat up a cop what I think
well it's domestic violence I would have
to be in her house yeah but then she we
started like whooping the cops know
she's not doing no she's looking good
what's what happened
she was the ageless one Oh dude remember
how hot she was oh do you have Kevin
Smith yes
our boy killer Smith had a heart attack
oh no a massive heart oh no our pets
heads are falling off uh uh but he
survived so it's good
Oh hold up massive heartache he's
shooting a special comedy special in
Glendale enduring his special he did the
first one and then the second one so
here he goes here I was trying to do a
killer stand-up specialist evening I'm
I've got
too far after the first show I felt kind
of nauseous I threw up a little bit see
the thing these fellas the things I felt
anyways but your chest didn't go heavy
no I threw up a little but did seem to
help then I started sweating buckets my
chest felt heavy turns out I had a
massive heart attack the doctor who
saved my life told me I had a hundred
percent blockage in the artery known as
the Widowmaker yep he says he's gonna
watch his diet now I might go vegan well
you know that apparently according to
Dean Ornish going vegan actually
reverses heart disease I'm sure there's
other ways too but Jesus I always
assumed I'd die screaming like my dad
who lost his leg to a massive heart
attack
well that ah that sucks okay but even if
they cut into my groin to slip a stent
into the lethal Widowmaker I was filled
with a sense of calm yeah I love Kevin
Smith yeah one of my favorite guest of
all time in a brilliant man he's a great
hope you get better buddy yeah now we
love Kevin um go back to a home girl who
Heather Locklear for me though hey
please scan a video please play that no
audio
I love these what happened to poor girl
let's hear
whoo-hoo and I jumped it was domestic
disturbance if you just arrived in
Caesarea her voice in our arguing on I
said that's a terrible video TMZ Jesus
Christ ever his brother came to her home
and saw Heather and her boyfriend
fighting the brothers called 9-1-1 were
told the cops deserve that the boyfriend
had a visible mark so you don't did
struck three deputies what's wrong with
her she doing drunk drunken drugs maybe
subscription why what is it you know as
peoples there there
Oh Jack Wagner he's a great guy I don't
know that is oh he was on a soap of a
really cool guy this is what happens I'm
sorry but a lot of times when you see
people who were beautiful and made their
money I see the guy down there I worked
with him on MADtv [ __ ] hilarious
what's wrong he was a big soap star big
big soap star uh can you bring up Jack
Wagner now I worked with him 23 years
ago and when you're when you're your
commodity is your looks and it starts to
go away it can get ugly man it can get
[ __ ] ugly but he's a great guy man
still got it
the kids still got it I don't know dude
you need more than just fan out where
those chains like that don't wear those
changing on that shirt that's all or do
your hair like that Harris God we're
going on here like you're the kid off
[ __ ] you know and then you're not in
that boys don't do your hair like to
kill us step-by-step yeah that's a
little too he's a little too done up he
was on danceOn the Stars house I guess
so I don't know he is he was famous he
was a long time soap guy long time mr.
steal your girl that black turtle man
dude and and new acting nose acting a
good actor gave me notes and helped me
in a sketch barely knows how to take a
punch
uh yeah probably boy oh boy that's a
bummer
ii-i'll be alright was amazed that
people implode like that but I guess
when it all when the music stops and you
don't know where else to go
would you mind music you mean looks when
the fame when the morale dries up when
when when nobody wants you anymore it's
very [ __ ] hard when you've been famous
for that long well I can talk about
going to Sharon Stone's house right for
sure yeah I went to shower John's house
she looks amazing she would hold his
Sharon Stone 16 dude and I'm not
all-time great all-time great dude who
is she ridiculous she still looks
amazing
I'll open him oh my god he's 59 smoke
[ __ ] so also been famous and I'm one
when I say famous I've been a she's been
a [ __ ] um she's been an icon
she's been royalty and she's been
treated like royalty for that long
always um she comes downs in her house
her crib very what will you make yours
look like a hut here's what she and she
said this on the podcast so it's fine
and I'm not speaking out of turn because
I want to be careful of her pony I give
out her address
she she's got a great crib but it's
classic it's classy and you know the
training stuff you know she's been doing
since she's been working since the 80s
saving money yeah you know how she saved
money though you know she's been saving
money
she's been she takes 10% of her income
always in buys art and she has an
amazing eye for art so I look at these
two skills the special but I looked at
these two insane paintings that we were
flanked by in her living room and I go I
go who made these I believe this was
recorded so it's okay I go who did these
and she goes those are boss cats now
positive icecap maybe you know labels
yeah yeah I do me as well be I do and
you and I are not art guys and if we
know who he is
there's like 12 paintings of his mother
she's got the originals and they're
trying I'm telling you the aliens
they're probably they're probably 20
million each you know you know postcards
they used to make when he's homeless are
going see I love the you know yeah I'm a
basket she's got they're bigger than
this wall they wouldn't fit on this wall
okay he's african-american man yes
readiness but brilliant that's not him
that's Bousquet don't ever bring up the
rock Basquiat jump all basket there is
that there but either way dude she has
some she has a famous art collection
that's in there jay-z bought up one of
his paintings for like 40 million
dollars and she's not talking to you
about acting she'll talk to you about
quantum physicist physics
she'll talk to you about does she have a
background of that she's just fascinated
with it she's called scientists and has
like two hour long conversation
interesting yeah her her success is not
a mistake it's not never anyone even
with the Paris Hilton's of the world now
that no that's just by mistake I got
lucky right Bob there's this long Julian
lucky for ten minutes you're not gonna
get lucky for thirty years
looks like it's like standeth how many
people had told us like there might be a
famous guy that goes well I'm gonna try
Stanley gets up there that fame will
give him maybe a minute-to-minute leeway
then after that people go now go correct
sir then you got to make them laugh you
are correct sir that's right
and I looked at that and she bought
those paintings in the 80s oh my god the
Atheist she's she's that she's that
Beverly Hills and and you better not and
don't and don't be cheeky with her and
don't start with that you know what's
really question yeah but we had a good
conversation she was she was she's a
single mom now she she has two three
sons I think she adopted yeah
she's saying the brother no no she's
she's delicious is she still kill she's
still delicious
you had a picture for me we took a
picture but she's you know she'll seduce
the home phone it's not it's not I'll
get it for how does that not happen
I know hunter tailpiece took it killer
Krim yeah but tasteful
I only saw not haughty I only show you
bend those certain parts yeah I would
trust you though this is where a family
that I didn't want to you know and I'll
pick I'll steal things
well yes I got I got a case of the
sticky fingers she's still acting she
just finished doing mosaic which my
buddy at Salomon who wrote men in black
he wrote he paired up with Steven
Soderbergh HBO monsters and yeah
monsters and they wrote mosaic which is
a [ __ ] dude she's brilliant yeah she
and I said to her I said who are you
she's asking always really intelligent
she's a disaster artist that's right and
I was like you don't I go you did never
became a victim of your good looks
you just what you say what we just
talked about the idea that we also
talked a little bit about acting having
to manage
Fame you talk about that like the acting
world and stuff like that Fame you talk
about Fame
now you say about Fame and what about
the house tea
do you know what I love about her when
they go putting about this little
hashtag me to move it have you dealt
with that and she started laughing
starte laughing she's excuse me yeah I'm
Sharon Stone in that game well well well
you can see it you're not you're not she
she knows how to hang out of reach and
get wood you know she's she said she
goes I was busy doing work
I was busy just doing even bad movies
but getting better at my craft that's
all grew up on a farm man grew up in the
woman oh god oh god she told me and I
can remember medval Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania
she's a I mean you know and she was that
woman when she was young that every man
in the world would eat out of her hand
so she had power all you got her here
right now yeah yeah people treat her
like royalty her face is my buddy Johnny
Frechette was an acting cleanser her
face is painfully beautiful yeah yeah
well not that one chick got to make sure
it's good here are you shooting out of
all the pictures that's good about the
top left one in the eighties chin my god
that's my girl right there I would fight
you bro you and I would you I would rip
your old dick off for sure what wouldn't
you hit her huh that's where you would
pull eat you'd have to who shoved me out
of the way that deflection for sure just
like Tommy there she's won all t be a
case of baboon silver bro bro hey man
said single what you said she said yeah
I'm just gonna go into her house what it
take a hey bro let me just walk it out
hey I haven't only going first
hey what do you have her digits yeah I
got her digits but you know I might be
ever assistance digits they're on my
phone what do you those are your
assistants digits
actually you know whatever email you
leave oh i'm not emailing her hey sure
just checking in great combo today him
around the neighborhood where's a good
place to eat that's right do you like
jazz he call me Center right down there
we go
she's she's fantastic she's fantastic
yeah but she do her and the specialist
when I was a kid
a jackoff you don't have to wind up with
that dude okay that Canyon is her in
casino what she's hooking up with uh
Robert De Niro that's your man yeah and
then and then our boy from Joe Pesci's I
can't come in takes her head doom yeah
FAT FAT FAT FAT FAT FAT FAT that's what
when Wilson you know she's gonna hear
this maybe and be like dude I love my
house she's used to it nah man I was
very impressed with her as a person very
impressed
oh you don't make it to her this long
she's done the reading she don't know
look at that she look at that yeah she
looked at her look so famous her looks
were always sort of you know it was like
a form of bemused detachment like yeah
that's what I have but I'm more into
being effective yet the cute thing to
say that's very cute to say in this
culture but no look you got roles cuz
you smoked so there you go yeah that
would cause a lot of problems I love you
too she may appear I'll look it up dony
did you see what cut her type is you
know I mean hey yeah she was married to
a producer for a while her and uh Leslie
Turner
oh dude do you remember her in old Total
Recall yeah but she [ __ ] over oh yeah
what's [ __ ] and by the way dude that's
that's the movie where I saw her and I
went oh god yes good job I'm gonna ask
you to please take it easy with that a
handsome guy that's a super handsome guy
way better facial hair than me yeah
that's a handsome son of a [ __ ]
does that its name you what wikipedia
her who is that guy
there's a dating website dating with
Leslie Turner that they've just like who
dated who yeah watch well there's rancor
but strange you know this website David
DeLuise I'm not familiar with him oh I
know David he's my buddy oh no David
Dom DeLuise his son Dave's of Giroud
Eskimo brothers you hooked up with no I
did dammit you just did a podcast he's a
same thing that David DeLuise [ __ ]
beautiful baby get her number get us
some parents I said dude I love sir no
you have it emailed David is a great
final you ever I love that guy Wow miss
nasty miss David David Luiz he's a big
hand right what else you got chin I love
David
well chase Dreyfus who is that guy chase
Dreyfus I will come in steal right now I
will feel her right scanner get stupid I
brought Rick Fox okay
yes Rick's the mad Jake compete with
Rick Fox yeah of course you can I can't
either [ __ ] this locks been there
look at those long hands look at that
beautiful hey so we're not talking much
Sharon Stone that is Rick Rick so good
looking at oh it's a paint and a great
guy and a great and huge day we gotta
get him on a podcast man I would love to
we just grill about Sharon Stone listen
man
let's not say grill hot cast I mean I
ain't talking about her email listen
Rick Fox takes all the girls Oliver all
of you and I you and I you and I look
like mom do you want to bring Luke Rocco
bring whoever you want what do you want
to bring Oh Luke Rocco you think you
bottle no Rick Rick Fox and he original
vaccine cleaner
he's the vacuum cleaner okay we're
sitting there with our little shark
those little handheld things would like
the help he comes in the DS that one of
those giant magnets in the in the
cartoon right everything [ __ ] breach
yeah including the guys we all get
sucked up you know I wear those electric
scooters that [ __ ] boys look right look
he is a goddamn Lamborghini yeah he is
from I believe originally from either
Jamaica or Trinidad or heaven or have x1
chin what else yep dammit all right he's
cool I just thought Craig versus he's
super stuff good guy tell hilarious a
good man beast of a common yep gross -
I'm just a good guy from heat skull and
sig big great show he wrote oh yeah oh
he's done serious he's hilarious
dang it's gonna be tough to compete with
all this what else you got I can't
oh that's Phil Bronstein yeah they were
they were made for a while
Sharon sound Dweezil Zappa he's a nice
guy I seem to know everybody sees that
potatoes grow enough keep going
Eric Clapton yeah hooked up rumor has it
they hooked up you damn right you know
what you know his nickname is right you
know what isn't it you know what Eric
Clapton's nickname I sure do
fingers Clapton close Slowhand
yes that's a great it is was a carrot
clapping first celebrity I ever saw when
I was in New York City I was trying to
be an actor and I went to this really
cool underground club I belong I didn't
belong there and it's where you see
these when I was a young man 21 22 I saw
these women that were throwing and I saw
Eric Clapton there with this beautiful
woman and I was like it's like looking
at like you're a young man and it's like
seeing your first line at the zoo holy
please reasoning right there that's Eric
Clapton like that's you know they call
me and even deal you know what they call
me what it's not I didn't give myself
long Tom the mailman what's happening
man that you deliver I deliver mmm
through the back male men don't deliver
through the back though I understand
no I'm like ups I'll drop it off in the
back yeah I see I don't think that's a
good nickname does he have to explain
that you're no mailman so you take you
coming through the big [ __ ] doggy style
or what does that mean her or you go to
the back panel down you going dropping
the boxes off you going into South bad
the terrible metaphor man I'm just slow
hand is slow hand all right
I'm slow hand you know I'm saying all
right all right you don't like the
mailman than that man that's a really
ring it's not gonna stick you know I'm
saying bro you don't think what you're
part of like oh [ __ ] there's the mailman
yeah I call the mailman
yeah cuz he drops everything through the
bag but cuz they go what mail men
usually drop things in the front I don't
that's wrong I know but he's like it's
like what can big brown do for you and
he drops in the back you know my buddy
used to Joe Jana more whoo-hoo
our very wealthy buddy he's the worst
with metaphors the worst with metaphors
you know you gotta shoot for the stars
cuz you've missed the stars but you
might just end up dropping on a cloud
I'm like hey or he goes she could be as
fat as this rock and he pointed to a
rock and it was like a small rock how's
it work terrible
how about me Jay we're eating and is
right in between shows reading this
great Thai food out there and I went you
know it's a bummer we just talked about
life and you know it's a bummer now with
the internet and technology you can't
make up any more quotes like it's all
been done before like you can do it
somewhere it's been done yeah yeah how
about Shakespeare they caught you know
with fraudulent stuff and he's copying
people I mean even the old guys man
we'll find out stuff about them you
can't come with stuff anymore in Jay
sitting and thinking and we started
talking about the great office we talked
about sports we started talking about
the greatness of the Golden State
Warriors and he Jays obsessed with the
Bulls the 92-93 bulls and that was his
thing and he knows the history of the
NBA
no Jay knows I'm sure and goes you know
why the DTS you know why the Golden
State will never be the Chicago Bulls
like 93 both of you I goes because man
the Bulls you know if they're a team
they they didn't taking nights off they
don't take nights off whose greatness
doesn't take nights off and then he goes
oh there's a quote I made that google it
because greatness does not take breaks
you just speaking naturally about the
Bulls if you guys were down here I would
have come down just to hang out oh dude
you had your party but it um I could
have come down Friday night you should
have [ __ ] anyway but this doesn't take
the night off
there it is let's keep going keep going
all right yeah he's a he's a town we'll
steal his girl right now yep David
company's got a dick on him he's pretty
funny he's got a dick he's a hand model
Zoolander but he's got a dick I mean I
have that same coat with us yet his dick
goes on for days don't know oh my god we
get her there she's gorgeous keeps her
unfair about look at her wait go back at
first I go back first
Oh Bill Clinton I got a story about that
yeah look
look at her for a second just take that
in for a second what's the story bro I'm
just looking at this far away pants them
cuz that's a free country
cuz it's a free country it is cuz it's a
free cuz there's other dudes in the room
free country
oh the mayor ends here God don't don't
drop the mail off in my mailbox
drop it round back that's what you hear
behind the closed door when Bray drop
all packages around the back drop it
round back mailman yeah you know that
[ __ ] went down you know that [ __ ] went
down
god bless I bet he has I bet Bill
Clinton has the best dick game you've
ever seen I've read stories about him by
his by the sheriff's and the deputies
that would escort him to hotel rooms to
have sex with you know his girls his
side pieces and no judgment on that and
he would eat he said they said he had
such enormous appetites first of all the
guy literally only needs about four
hours of sleep at night Tom James when
he would eat an apple they said you'd
watch him eat an apple sexy and he would
eat an apple and he'd eat the core and
the seeds and the status Erick it just
didn't yeah he was like he just ate it
all up
poor cuckoo just yeah hook up with all
the everybody said that [ __ ]
intellect I had a for multiple min for
brilliant like brilliant and an alpha
male beyond my formidable producer on my
show Gabe Goodwin said he was at this
thing and you know he's been TV so long
and they said Bill Clinton had he was
given a speech and he was there and they
said they had a whole projector yeah and
he could he would read it they go off
and just throwing stuff no one went over
throw it in and it was beautiful on yeah
I think could just go right back and
pick up right on so he would go offer a
tangent for 20 minutes yep come right
back weave into the story yeah and then
he also also would have to had this huge
compound I forget where is it where was
that up there and then just down the
street would have his you ever seen
another place where he would make some
yeah yeah yes he had a formidable temper
a terrifying temper you ever seen you're
seeing him from camera freaked out know
when when that [ __ ]
when when Pete went to freak out who's
African people are starting to get
crushed in the front and he he flipped
out at the crowd watch this dude their
favorite President Bill Clinton
President Obama now hold on there's a
clear the right guy yeah I know no no no
it was it was it was when he was it was
in Africa is now Africa and he he didn't
take any [ __ ] you see this stuff and
dude how about Bill Clinton's dick
sucked in the White House the room we
were in yeah the Oval Office he got a
blowy yeah that's insane [ __ ] there's
and there was a clip and you can see him
and you just I get I get mo back my back
and he loses it for a second because he
try to save people in the front it was
[ __ ] you could feel I was like oh my god
that guy's a bad [ __ ] just
check this one oh this was when Chris
Matthews tried to a Chris at least I
tried that's the difference in me and
some including all the right wingers
that are attacking me now they ridiculed
me for trying
they had eight months to try they did
not try I tried so I tried and failed
you can see that I watch that interview
i watch that he didn't weigh Bill
Clinton Savage I'm sorry they don't have
that clip so I'm gonna have to find it
but but I'm yeah he was arrested Kern
events June we've been balls Jimmy go
just a couple more with Sharon Stone
just to see if we have anything to say
about them I think it's probably
important a little bit we got maybe a
Michael Douglas we know that keep going
great actor shorter than you think way
shorter than you think Dwight Yoakam
phenomenal phenomenal keep going Paul
Verhoeven great director terrible teeth
yeah
Prince of Monaco he's everything so I'm
talkin it could be she had a fling all
right oh there is you know he is wrote
and directed showgirls and and Basic
Instinct okay that's great however
Sharon well the bride knows they should
Luke listen II yeah little prize I gotta
move my nose out of the way so I can eat
s no this is growing in over his lips
his nose is right over his looked he
looks like
shoots ropes yeah yeah he shoots heavy
ropes with those he was uh yeah he put
it down in Hollywood keep going for a
second keep going John F Kennedy jr.
dude that's mister I used to see him in
New York rollerblading with a shirt off
or just hanging around you'd see in
periodically all the kids that somethin
guy you've ever seen dude how can you
compete my buddy took a shower next to
him my buddy carmine Provenzano to the
shower exhale man in in in at the end
New York athletically I believe and he
goes he goes and Karma's like this he
goes guys got a bigger dick than
everybody you know and I went he does
that too sure does probably wasn't the
smartest guy in the world he'll tried a
lot of things and failed
they killed good-looking and his brother
and obviously smart too though I didn't
have a brother that's John F Kennedy jr.
his father thought that was his father
oh yeah so that's his that's his son
it's his son your son keep going before
before before I freak the [ __ ] out now
there's Michael greenberg and that would
be Chris D'Elia
[Laughter]
obviously that's Chris the Chris has a
shot now yeah that's a dress like bolted
he's never dressed like that I wasn't
yet yep okay there's no tie on F Kennedy
jr. and he got Rick Fox we're all fun
you take his fingers in per second oh
man sighs me I don't want him putting
those up your shirt on check is your
prostate a guy I had a doctor do that
with with [ __ ] banana fingers like
that those are banana fingers doesn't
rot worse his fingers yeah those things
are I don't know if he's pushing air
into them I don't know what this is
obviously the deepness of your fingers
his mom his mom [ __ ] a Goodyear blimp
obviously because okay I'll see you as
five dicks four fingers that's right and
a hamburger patty as a [ __ ] palm hey
bro you swallowed the Michelin Man huh
your mom [ __ ] him is my man what's
going on Sharon's don't make you go Jim
Wow look at that hair I don't know that
guy oh man
keep going a tough man to pro that's a
bummer Sharif or Malik sir that
moustache you
gotta go at higher I don't like mustache
like that sir I'm gonna look at me right
now that I don't have space between your
nose and your mustache okay right now
that guy like though ever dick tears
well he's got a very he's got a crazy
eye he's got a crazy eye and he clearly
kills people you know he looks like he's
like a human version of a pug Doug he
carries it looks like you're plugged up
or he's a cane it doesn't need one and
he's a sadist any poisons being he kills
people at night like Jim what else yeah
he's Chinon he have my slobs way better
all right next one wow that's a I hate
when people don't grow their mustaches
properly yeah that's a handsome rogue
okay looks like you made some bad
decisions my heart bond here hey my name
is Hart Bakker
Elsie's going it's alright Bakker okay
Johnny Sanders she's all over the place
you still got a chance is some
conventions I do should we talk fight
for a second yeah and watch the fights
bro did did you see Stevens Emmett did
y'all problem with any of it I didn't
and I'll tell you why it's on the room
Stevens I mean first of all he dropped
him with that left hook he got that long
I've talked sure he did came back fight
great fight great fight and and Emmett
looked amazing but Jeremy Stephens if
you're gonna stand a bang and and you
know what I want to talk about this for
a second I'm so obsessed with striking
and all that but like obsessed I know
but but his ability to stand in the
pocket it was kind of like when when
Yancey tried to stand with cowboy those
guys who've been doing it so long they
can they can even in the fray they
somehow can if you get in that game with
them they're gonna catch you right
usually I mean if you swing him I don't
receive as just hit so hard but Emma was
laying in - but Emmett was it really
wasn't rate he was given out and didn't
have his hand high and got clipped it
wasn't the most technically wrong look
but that's that's why I get you when
you're getting out clear there you go
and then he kind of missed his head but
he was an eel mode Elmo that's on the
ref it's on the raft and it also didn't
it's not what he it's not how he won
that's not now it was gonna lose that
fight no matter what but everyone's
focused on that and it's it's silly you
gotta get with that fight no matter what
you got to give it up to - Stephen
Stevens is
is going to give max I can't wait till
he fights max Holloway well he's not
gonna be there next who's a winner Frank
Ryan or taking what's your what's your
call and Stevens because he was part of
55:41 deadly staying up 45 oh I think
they'll give him a Aldo next all that
although still ranked number one okay
I'm gonna give them all to a few ones
that you thought you bring that baby up
it depends on what happens with their
take in Frankie if someone gets injured
something like that cuz I'm sure max is
you know there's a lot of heroes to use
now I want to see him just I think he's
gonna be a nightmare for everybody
Jessica and Hyundai and t-shirt Torres T
stores look great
fought a great fight on Entourage is my
favorite straw was so strong was he her
and she's so strong she just she just
hunt you down and picks you up and
throws you on your [ __ ] head monster
I don't know how you do that now what
are you looking with like that man I
just was wondering
they are very muscular yeah hey look at
you looked at Jeff Novitzky nothing gets
by them and general how honestly I don't
know how anyone would do anything these
days that with those traps I'm just
wondering if if are you are you
suspicious is there a possibility
they're doing all the steroids or now I
know I'm being cuz there's not caught
but I'm allowed to say it be caught
though by now okay
now I'm back in the day did they do a
little you know yeah so you're saying
that's all natural okay good you why are
you smiling of y'all II okay I'm just
gone when I feel I'm just walk word yeah
yeah
both highly-skilled both looked amazing
so impressive teachers you say I
wouldn't be surprised if you found out
both of them were taking deca d-ball
like there goes Jim that's right and I
think and I think that's I think I'm not
being unfair I'm not being disrespectful
I think they'd be hot I I don't think
they had a high enough level to have the
high enough scientists get to pass the
goals and then they are just two freaks
in the freezer yeah that's that's real
muscularity and anyways we can move on
because obviously you're feeling
uncomfortable
so because it's fine
how about allelic tempers pretty wild
man ya got in there just kept getting in
there bang bang because that surprised
me call out DC now that fights up in the
air man anyone could win that I liked
with TPS the underdog in that yeah if
you're betting on it but I thought maybe
I was gonna pull it off but then the TV
does lock where DC call-out yeah hey DC
it beat the brake zone yeah
good night a fight zone there's fights
this weekend yep Frankie Edgar yacht
Brian Ortega yeah we got cyborg fighting
uh Mike Perry max Griffin that was
pretty interesting
max Griffin kind of came out of nowhere
right really yeah Perry needs time off
he's he's fighting too frequently don't
have the best camps his girl cornered
him he has some issues government yeah
yeah well there it is this weekend you
got jumped in water Ortiz on Showtime on
pay-per-view got Frankie Edgar Ortega
you got a side-by-side that's intriguing
fight Freddy get your tea you got a
great fight yeah I don't think I don't
think
Ortega's jujitsu works on Frankie Edgar
that's it I know who knows that's right
the industry because you know cup
Swanson's high level man yeah yeah he
based got cup twice yeah it's a great
fight I'm excited for it
any prediction on that me on the Frankie
Edgar I'm always calling with Mike
Haggar always I never bet against him I
think he's defies he defies physics you
got the dime piece McKenzie turn
fighting to making her debut that Jew
phenom yeah she's from Hawaii doesn't
know Brazil right Brazil yeah yeah I can
take a look at her for a sec yeah what's
your call Ortega a good fight I think
Frankie TKO via third round what about
her she's just she's gorgeous
yes that's that is that's well it's
crazy
and there's there and that's no help
there no there's no science and Lobo
that's just not right there's no doctor
touches you so like attractive right
yeah yeah it's ridiculous and
world-class you to one of the best
female judges to practice really well if
she teased as she teased probably want
some privacy
I gotta start silly right gotta start
taking my jujitsu way more seriously are
you gonna do something yeah I'll go the
bottom left one for me the word says
related images enough death that's not
her okay I just died so I thought that
was weird though yeah you gonna make
sure but if you're mad at that you know
let me know hold my words - all right
well yes I'm kind of interested yes god
bless her is right right let's start off
with this one here a transgender teen
who's a girl transitioning into a boy
she's want her second state competition
already she has to wrestle girls she's a
girl turning into a boy she's a girl
who's taking testosterone but she's
competing as a woman yeah I think
tattoos [ __ ] it's [ __ ] I think
she's beating the [ __ ] out of these
girls there's Alan let me ask you this
does she have the option and compete
with the boys now that's the problem so
she's what if you're her parents what
she must do not wrestle if their passion
I can tell exactly what I think you have
a woman taking testosterone so movies so
yeah peds sorry you could you don't get
to wrestle yeah if you're gonna make
this choice it's gonna come with
consequences one of them is that you you
you're not play the video for me it's
not fair I agree that's a good point be
like die if fashion if wrestling's your
passion can you wait to after high
school wrestling to take testosterone do
you have to do in high school just care
about wrestling you only could be in
wrestling can you just wake up and I
also think it's really weird that I know
Hollywood there are Hollywood kids
actors who have kids who are making the
transition that you play for Hannah 211
really are their brains developed enough
to make that choice for themselves or
can they wait till they're 18 oh man
people were hoping that that she lost
yeah people were booing
you can hear it
dan they're so happy that girl almost
won it's [ __ ] though I'm sorry I
mean it's it's it's it's not it's not
because people are transphobic either
know that but no I'm not Transpo can
help you neither
I don't think it's fair either I think
it's [ __ ] you basically got a girl
who's Jack to the gills on steroids and
and by the way and I want to this is a
really important point because what's
happening now is if you identify as a
woman you don't even have to do that so
so if I say I'm a woman but I'm a man
and I go to a woman's prison but I'm a
sex offender now what like it like this
this is getting you know kind of crazy
yikes that is great thing it's crazy
what does she get you it's not fitting I
don't think you should be in the
Olympics you're taking you're taking
peds you're a woman on massive amounts
of size I think they should be allowed
to compete but I think they should be in
their own division I think you have a
transgender division right great that's
a I agree with you I agree with you but
it's all it's gonna be all kinds of
drugs on both sides look at that you
know alright keep going alright next one
is a Russian Olympian who wore a shirt
that says I don't do doping she got
popped three days later that's hilarious
you did a commercial for two for this
clothing breath that is hilarious what'd
she get pop for that they didn't say
what it is Jim was she competed what was
it or something
that's hilarious I don't do doping and
then got busted yeah well well 12 feet
bobsleigh yeah for bobsled makes sense
what can you do what else you got sir
this is a crazy one a mom and her
daughter who work at a liquor store they
own it I had a armed robber come in and
then there was a shootout it's really
crazy check it out
that's a daughter on the counter on that
and the robber has a gun with him so
he's pointing a shotgun yeah so scary
god is good
keep watching so as he's leaving as he's
going away they're pulling out their
guns yeah they both take oh yeah oh yeah
well guys so he's coming back and now it
starts going off so the woman starts
firing to him he comes back holy SH I
watch you'll see some good girls gonna
shoot us good job gets even crazier wait
he comes back he comes back why this
guy's crazy this mom's gangster she kind
of doesn't give a [ __ ]
watch watch the Dodge truck called 91
he's coming back
oh [ __ ] so he gets shot multiple times
oh Sh and now they're arguing and then
what the [ __ ] he's crazy this crazy
why is she shot he's going after her Oh
mom so she oh [ __ ] guy damn is he
Robocop the guy grabs the the mom's gun
too so check this out
why does why did the daughter shoot him
because she's terrified why don't you
try she does she won't she wants but she
doesn't hit her mom oh you should show
up sir
oh she just shot she just shot her now
he's still after them he's getting shot
left and right yeah dude he's been shot
how many times dude he's the Terminator
this guy just needs to get his stuff he
he was involved in like eight other
robberies - dude she's been shot how
many times yes I'm amazing
did he die no I'm so crazy man did he
get shot down here here here here small
gun for how much money yeah I mean small
guns things aren't working out oh my god
it's just crazy you got to be crazy and
that's and there did the job the moms
get shot none of them got shot holy [ __ ]
God so the mom when she was when the guy
was trying to wrestle the gun away from
her she was worried about him shooting
so she tried to empty the clip yeah
before nope Wow damn that woman's a
super badass she probably took a lot and
then she knows the good daughters had a
gun yes she empties those Wow brilliant
man what a badass
what a badass but but also not to
celebrate this man he's been a badass
doing me and came back at them and
dropped his gun I'm taking the gun away
from you laughter with a bunch of little
edge
he's got beginner you can get need uh
never get jumped into any gang you guys
have I'm gonna be that's hard you took
some life that's hard yeah yo what's he
going after you know if I had to guess
hot cheetos say man and diesel oh my god
well hey life-threatening but later says
he's all good
[ __ ] he deserves a warm me to
bottle his blood took a couple she fell
down got back up I got [ __ ] I'm hurting
my word hit nothing vital what its get
two straight one you know Steve Wilkos
from yeah Channel alive he wasn't a
horrific wreck you can see her air Oh
God he was just drunk and just slamming
into everything and apparently he blamed
it on something else before but then he
turned himself in on Wednesday because
he was three times over the limit of
alcohol and yeah if you guys know his
show he's like a like a saint well he's
like a sob right for recovery so never
know I don't know if he's a cop I don't
either is what it is but uh anyways yeah
thanks
yeah that Margot Robbie yeah no that's
not her in the middle no that's that one
girl Michelle Pfeiffer Rebecca Gayheart
no she was on a thing Tiger Woods was
like Jada [ __ ] well he's got that
[ __ ] ghost those eyelids why you can
see the whites under his eyes but you
know I'm saying like when you got those
which I teared
yeah things aren't going well well she
sees her name Roby's greatness never
mind oh that's my tartar aircar that's
his little brother he's also a game in
and then there's tiger exhibit there
Chris Kattan alright anyways Oh Chris
yeah that was it yeah those were
hilarious man
there you go oh there yeah that's funny
man so big this thing is a legend yeah
guys you can take some lead keep on
coming keep on if I got Tribeca what the
[ __ ] out run right sue us altogether I
got too much to live for
I'm out oh so I should shout out to
those two ladies she actually hit I
won't if she hits him here she hit
though he goes back in not backing down
so funny man be where you gonna be stand
up is it this this one say my brother uh
we're selling very well in Melrose
improv this Wednesday eight o'clock
I think Kevin Nealon is gonna open for
me oh I love study here hopefully I hope
other way it's gonna be great I'm doing
an hour and then I got Huntsville
Alabama you filthy animals come out if
you're in the area flying to Nashville
and I'm driving a Huntsville how you do
it yeah and Huntsville is gonna be a lot
of fun I can't wait it's gonna be March
8th 9th and 10th at stand-up live get
your tickets at t5k calm Booya I'm in
Oxnard March 16th and 17th levity live
Oxnard come and get it and then I'm in
Florida in late March
Tampa sold out on the 22nd West Palm
Beach 23rd 24th and then Orlando on
Sunday that is March 25th and then San
Jose at the end of the month we just
mounted San Jose improv March 29th
through the 31st and then Bakersfield
April 6 get tickets now tea fat Kay Tom
we love you guys this is the fiery kid
we're out